第六章交易选择权
2015年底
在台湾股市持续挟幅盘整的情况下
我开始接触选择权这项商品
选择权当时主要获利的方式是收取时间价值
更难能可贵的是
比起台纸期不是多就是空
选择权多了非常多的策略组合
正是因为如此
尽管我还是可以从台股和台纸期上获利
但交易重心也开始渐渐转移到选择权上
还记得当时也有去旁听一门课财务工程
课堂上除了教授以外
还有许多硕士生
博士生都对选择权类型的模型非常有研究
毕竟选择权算是依据理论最有机会赚钱的商品
这门学科太大了
但讲白话一点
在台湾的选择权市场中
套利做得最好
最快的就是某一两家外资高频公司
当其他人速度比不赢
资金设备也判不赢的时候
就是比谁能急着多冒一些风险
来建立出一套能够获利的类套利模型
也就是说
这个模型的风险会稍微比套利的无风险高一些
不过
课堂上许多研究
写论文的教授和博士生
都仅止于学术上的研究
甚至于连期货户头都没开过
这一点我到现在都觉得可惜
身为一个交易员
在我了解理论面之后
当然要想如何在其中获利
然后我发现到
因为选择权与台纸期
都是大盘的衍生性金融商品
而选择权与台纸期
是不可能脱钩的
所以换句话说
我看盘判断走势的方式
其实可以不用改变
我只要改变交易商品
就可以让盘整式的绩效变得更好
举例来说
当我交易台纸期时
虽然多空都可以赚钱
但遇到盘整时期
要不就是因而赔钱
或是被迫拉低风险值
降低交易频率
再不然就只能休息
但开始交易选择权之后
当股市遇到盘整时期
我就多出了一种交易方式
就是等待时间价值的流逝
而选择权因为可以进行吊单
边按因选择权的时间价值特性
在下单后若发现方向有误
还可以对既有交易进行调整
例如平仓后再重新下单
或以新的单来锁住风险等
因此允许投资者稍微有些许看错的区间
这就是俗称的一只脚 两只脚 三只脚 四只脚
选择权是一门非常大的交易系统
恐怕不是花几页减数
就可以让大家理解
在选择权这方面若有兴趣的读者
可以上网搜寻资讯
强烈建议
也可以进一步去了解财务工程
因时间价值流失并非线性
而是在距离结算时间越近时会越快
因此除了每周三的周选择权结算以外
其实平常盘中是不太会流失的
这时候的选择权主要都是流仓交易
边按
之所持部位尚未平仓
价格仍受到市场价格变动的影响居多
比起台指期当冲
选择权流仓的最大缺点
就是需要保证金边按
选择权买方只需支付权利金
卖方则需支付保证金
而台指期当冲会强制每日收盘时冲销部位
因此选择权流仓时
保证金无法动用
与台纸期当冲不同
且毕竟属于杠杆交易
相同部位之下保留资金越多
绝对风险也就越低
因此这段时间对我而言
也是生活上相对较刻苦的时期
并不是说这段时间的钱赚的少
而是因为我秉持着尽可能保留资金
即已降低风险的概念
几乎完全不出金
前阵子正好新闻疯狂放送
快炒电白饭之乱的新闻
让我想起自己过去这段时期中
虽然已不再是学生
资产也已经比同辈多出数十倍以上
但我却过得非常节俭
那时我尽管住台北市
房子租在信义区
但给自己的生活预算
就是一天不超过200元
那时市面上常见的是
50元的三菜一煮餐便当
只不过所谓的鸡排
鱼排永远都是油炸
包住一层厚厚的皮
吃不到肉
当时我每天几乎都是用自助餐果腹
加五块咸猪肉
一汤匙番茄炒蛋
就去结账
当时老板每次都收我五十元
还会特意提醒我
你长那么高大
怎么吃那么少
我们有提供炒饭炒面吃到饱
饮料也是喝到饱
你尽管吃
吃白饭还可以加卤汁
还记得我每次都是趁着自助餐块打烊
不怕我吃的时候
边等老板聊天边大块朵一
每次可以吃掉将近十碗白饭或炒饭
不只觉得很有饱足感
而且也对这份温情铭记在心
就这样过了两三年
只不过吃饭实在容易胖
每次回老家
父母亲还会叫我减肥少吃一些
所以现在每当有人向我借钱
或听到有人在哀嚎没钱的时候
看出他们一餐动辄吃掉两百元
尽管没钱还是得去娱乐消费
还是得去吃大餐
我都会笑笑待过
回想着自己过去曾经度过那样的生活
不禁佩服起当时的自己
也深深感谢自己撑过来了
时间来到2016年底
当时我偶然间注意到
网路上有个人
时常公开分享自己的选择权
对账单与我不同的事
他做的是选择权当冲
而且胜率异常的高
这激起了我的好奇心
刚好有位共同朋友
知道我们都在做选择权
于是居中牵线介绍我们认识
我称他为龙眼
和他聊过后
发现他和我最大的不同在于
他是做周选择权
且是做当冲
调单手法
看盘方式则是大同小异
它赚取的是周选择权
日内流失的时间价值
尤其每到周三
周选择权时间价值会归零
更是它获利的主要来源
而我赚的是月选择权的时间价值
但原本就觉得以月为单位的流仓交易
不管是时间或交易频率
都不是那么适合自己的个性
我因为交易月选择权
在月选择权结算当天
本来就会进行较多的交易
了解它的做法后
我被激起了交易魂
也开始做起周选择权当冲
从月选择权跨到周选择权当冲
其实调单逻辑
手法等都大同小异
只是交易速度与判断速度加快许多
我大约一两个月左右就适应了
不过因为速度需求提升
同时网络设备
软硬体设备的需求提高
因此这时我便应邀到期货商
VIP室内进行交易
每月成交量大约在十万口之谱
不知道是纯粹运气好
还是因为我贴着市场预测
对应走势的操作手法奏效
这段时间的交易
也是持续稳定赚到钱
在交易选择权当冲
一阵子之后
七交所宣布
将于2017年5月15日
上线夜盘交易制度
当我得知夜盘即将开放的时候
第一个想法就是
我不用睡觉了
以周选择权的时间价值统计来说
应有周休二日不可掌控的因素
通常周四与周五时间价值流失较慢
甚至可能因波动率提升而到涨
最好做且时间价值会明显流失的时期
则是周一到周三结算
也是我最主要的交易时段与获利来源
夜盘开放没多久
我就想到如果我把原本的日内当冲交易
拉长到周一开盘开始做
做到周三结算日
那我不就可以只承受当冲的风险
可以及时调整部位
而得到流仓的利润
在这个想法驱使下
我开始了一段堪称疯狂的交易狂人时光
每个周一到周三
白天在券商立IP时交易完之后
趁着夜盘在下午三点开盘之前
我会赶紧买好食物回到家中电脑前
就这样交易到半夜五点
当时我与钱文提到的龙爷
还有另一位好兄弟宝爷
共创一个LINE群组
在夜深人静
夜盘也没行情的时候
大家边聊着天边调住单
就这样做到快天亮
真是一段难忘的时光
还记得夜盘才刚开始
可能市场上的城市交易者和造势商
还在测试与修改自身的交易系统
因此市场的流动性非常差
甚至手动就可以进行期货与选择圈套利
per-cow parity
我们的做法并不因为时段式夜盘而有所变动
而刚开放夜盘的时期市场上较少参与者
很快的
我们的交易就占据夜盘市场中
非常大的成交量
也遇到相当多有趣的故事
例如有一次
半夜四点多时
因为美股已经没什么波动
我们几个正准备收工要去睡觉
没想到此时苹果财报突然公布
在那个时候
苹果的财报是非常能够左右
全球市场气氛的指标
我还记得在财报公布后
全球期货往上拉了一大根
眼看台湾市场没有怎么跟随
再看看我们两人手上持有的数百口的部位
与市场情况一对比
发现扣掉我们的挂单后
市场上几乎没剩几口了
于是当下互通电话后
决定要轮流调单
就这样你调一下我调一下
眼看着市场整体走势
几乎要被我们的操作影响
夜盘就要大涨了
我们又讨论了一番
最后决定你不出我不出
现在市场上就我们两个在这样做动作
有可能原本市场没要涨那么多
过了三小时后
换台湾开盘了
果然如我们所料
市场开小高之后
才慢慢往上走
我们没硬着头皮
再没流动性时出场
是对的
确认完以后
我们这才维持原本的步调
继续调单了
第七章交易股票期货
2017年
在市场持续盘整一段期间之后
逐渐产生变化
首先
股市投机气氛
开始变得越来越热络
其中也陆续兴起一些所谓的妖股
股价遇到大波动的机会
也增加许
接着就是股票期货流动性
渐渐变得兴旺起来
随着股票期货的兴起
加上我做选择权当冲的重心
是摆在周三结算日
而且这些年的交易经历中
虽然我投注不少时间
在做台指期货
选择权
但看盘重点始终还是摆在股票现货上
在我了解股票期货的优势之后
自然也开始跃跃欲试
开始考虑交易这个商品
因此
虽然我主要还是在做台指期
选择权当冲
但在闲暇之余
我开始学着交易股票期货
而这次的新尝试
就不像先前从台纸器衔接到选择权
可以那么轻松转换
毕竟从概念来说
这次是从指数的衍生性金融商品
变成操作股票的衍生性金融商品
但我依据股票期货的规则
马上抓到其商品的优势
可说让我减少了许多的时间与成本
举凡像是交易时产生的手续费
税金等
在交易股票现货的时候
一旦看错
拼出的成本实在是很高
而相对的
对我而言
股息最大的优势
就是可以看免费的
对我来说
看得准
预测得准
一直以来都不是交易时的重点
其实
减是我的个人绩效
可以说是看得非常不准
准确率几乎可以类比成像支硬币一样
只有50胜率
所以在这种情况下
对我来说
看对赚多少
看错赔多少就是最大的重点
这边要说明一下
我这边提到的看错
并非只是单纯像人家所谓的赔多少停损
假设我觉得行情要发动了
结果单子打进去股价没动
这种情况我也称为看错
关于看错的定义
后面还会再详细提到我的看法
而当交易股期时
发生这种行情没有发动的看错状况
相对于台股现货就有非常大的优势
做股期时
我可以有非常多次免费的看错打进去不对没动走打进去报。就这两句话,大概就是我交易股票,股器的一切重心所在。
而在股器上,最大的优势就在于没动,走的时候,因股器在试错时的成本与手续费。
比起交易股票要便宜许多,甚至几乎可以说是零成本了。
另外一个优势是时间差。
在我开始研究股期的时候
股票还是五秒撮合的制度
但期货已经是逐笔撮
读者们可以留意
凡是这类同质性的交易商品
例如
股期是依照股票现货价格进行结算
就属于同质性
若两边的交易制度不相等
绝对都会有价差
甚至还可能产生套利机会
一直到2024年为止
还是有很多商品能找到这种机会
诸如ETF
权证等
甚至连期货选择权也是
例如目前股票现货已经改成主笔撮合
但期货结算还是依照五秒钟为单位
算出简单的算术平均
所以这里的套利机会
也已经变成市场参与者的军备竞赛
只是有资格参与者实在太少
举台积电为例
差一个Tick对于加权指数的影响是五点
那只要谁在每一次取加的最后一笔丢一张
例如全部丢买单
当周的加权指数平均就会多五点
不要小看这五点
依照期货
选择权为平仓的数据来计算
这五点的差距可能可以差到数亿
所以所谓的军备竞赛
比的是谁能在这一盘价格出来钱
精准丢在最后一笔成交
而且这影响的金额非常庞大
话题稍微有些扯远了
但这就是时间差非常重要的地方
当时还有一种很简单
也很直觉的交易模式
就是盯着现货的成交明细
当股价往上或往下跳的瞬间
股息价格波动往往有时间差
有时甚至差到一秒之久
只要能掌握住这个瞬间
搭配前面提到看错不用钱的特点
就可以得到不错的获利
直到2024年的今日
还是有非常多这种机会
当我掌握这两个优势与逻辑不久后
在股息的交易也开始获利
当时股息的流动性逐渐增加
但跟股票还是没得比
可能一天成交量超过一千口的
就只有三只左右的股票
像是当时环球金股期
算是很热门的标的
尽管我用了热门这个说法
实际上挂单还是不多
有15档加起来可能不到5口
而且挂单价格还离得很远
环球金虽然没有好的流动性
却是当充客们很爱它的标的
而且还愿意划价来进出场
因此我就利用这个特点来进行交易
以下说明当时的交易手法
给大家参考
假设现货价格在400元
当下如果看多
我会先在几个价位各挂两口卖单
例如403
407等几个价位
然后再挂399
等有人卖出因为单量少
有一阵子几乎一半以上挂单
都是我挂的
如果行情真的很看好
认定会涨很多时
我会吃下400
402的挂单
这样当行情真的发动时
由于前面提到
当冲客会不计价格
滑价紧出场
因此他们就会去点我上面的卖单
这样我就能顺利出场了
若行情趋势很强时
我还可以从低价一路往上抽单
比人家要出场只能继续往上点
当然也有看错行情的时候
一口股票期货等于两张股票现货
所以股票期货流动性出现问题
或是部位太大时
如果要出场
通常我都会选择用现货
把部位锁起来
前述这样的交易手法
有一阵子获利不错
直到有一天
环球经真正的主力出现了
当天状况是
现货挂单挂得满后的
每一档唯买尾卖
都至少有几十张以上
而股期依旧大部分是我的挂单
在这样的情况下
我被这只股票真正的控盘者修理了
主力在一秒内
吃掉我五档所有的尾卖
合计约十二口
当伪卖被吃的瞬间
我看了一下现货还是挂很满
心里想说应该是有人挂市价大口输物吃
但因为我也出不掉我的卖单
那时五档挂单可能不到五口
于是打算去买进24张环球金先锁起来
当下若以现货成交价锁起来的状况
应该是会获利的
就在这个时刻
主力把五档卖单的几百张全部抽单
然后在成交价17档的地方
成交一笔70几张的大单
当时还是五秒撮合
看到这种状况
我马上就知道是被修理了
编案
此处提及被修理
是因环球晶有特定控盘者
在操控股票和期货的价格
控盘者有点类似法人
通常每天就是控制一个特定方向
买进或卖出
而当大资金经常捣乱时
他们会出手修理
好让对方退出他们的标的
作者当时发现此套利机会
并进行低买高卖的交易
但被环球晶的控盘者修理
让作者高挂卖出的价格直接成交
强迫他在更高的位置停损回补
也因为怕大家以为股价要发动
反而继续推升股价造成更大的损失
还是任命买24张环球晶停损
主力发现我停损完
环球晶现货价格马上又下来恢复正常
这次的交易算是一笔蛮大的停损
但是也因为这次的交易
让我得到不少交易股票现货的想法
也就是所谓的控盘手法
在此也要提醒一下
想要学做当冲客的投资者
所谓免钱的最贵
这句话当然也是用在交易上
方间常看到一堆平台或老师
为了收学费而打出五本当冲广告
但你得了解
其实做当冲绝对不是真正的五本
在你按下去那瞬间
就注定要矫正交税与券商手续费
而股票期货却可以真的做到类似五本
跟股价涨跌幅相比
交易成本几乎为零
如果能掌握住股票期货特有的优势
例如前面提到的
看股票发动在抓紧时机去打股气的时间差优势
操作上相对股票会稍微简单一些
另外一个交易优势是
当你放空被锁涨停时
幸运的话你可以改成融券留仓空单
不幸运的话
没有融券可以改名目
可能会赔到一日期的借券费
而股票期货被锁涨停
却没有这些问题和这些费用
另外一点就是
有时候股票涨停
这时候虽然现货所死
但同一时间内
股期却还可以买得到
这是因为很多股票所涨停的大户
并不会同时去操控股期
这时候现货和期货之间
就会出现非常大的差距
若你想买强势股
涨停标的流仓
现货买不到
不妨打开股期看看
我做股票期货
算是做了非常久
在我抓到赚钱技巧后
当然也是越打越大
直到有一天发现自己的成交量
已经几乎占全市场最热门标的成交量的50
加上其他专职股器的朋友
我们这小群人大概就涵盖整个市场的75
因为大家都没什么输赢
可见我们这些人只是在互按
而且一不小心
就会被做7
现货套利的造势者吃掉了
虽说当时的成交量状况
占最热门股器将近50的比例
但对比同一只标的的股票现货成交量
可能只有5
看到这个落差
我心里非常明白
在交易这条路上
如果想要往上突破
更上一层欧
终究还是要交易股票
于是
我就开始尝试将心力转换到做股票当冲
但制度是赚钱手法的最大天敌
举例来说
假如有一天台湾股市改成五涨跌幅限制
届时目前全市场最赚钱的手法
所涨停隔日冲就会彻底失效
而当冲交易将会进入全盛时期
当时股票撮合制度还是五秒撮合
我做股票当冲虽然没赔钱
但算是做得相当辛苦
明明原本想做股票市场
是想要让交易成果更上一层楼的
但交易起来的迹象
却远低于专注交易在股期的时候
我想原因在于
我先前所做过的交易
不管是台指期
选择权
海期
股期
全部都是主笔撮合
因此面对五秒成交一次的状况
不管是跳动模式还是速度
就比较不熟悉了
于是我开始引颈期盼
等住那期盼许久的股票
逐笔撮合到来
直到2020年3月
逐笔撮合终究是来了
第八章疯狂交易人生
前面提到
股息的流动性已经无法满足我了
我也从自己的成交量
在市场的占比看出
自己如果要更上一层楼
一定得开始做股票现火
因此
当政府公告2020年3月23日
要将现股撮合制度改成主笔撮合之后
我就一直在做准备
在那段期间
除了交易股票期货以外
我也开始做股票现货的当冲
当时一个月成交量约10亿上下
2020年3月23日的前一个营业日
在股市收盘后
我就把所有股票期货下单加全部关掉
心里想着
从明天开始
我就要将自己的交易100转成股票
即使一开始赔钱或是绩效比股期差也没关系
我一定要撑过去
绝对不回头
我就这样正式跟股期交易告别
从此之后
我全部的下单家都开股票现火
当主笔撮合正式上路以后
市场情况也符合我市前的预期
通常在新制度出来的时候
许多人因为习惯就制度
不习惯速度
甚至是设备
网络速度都跟不上
市场上顿时出现许多乱象
甚至还有些交易者
妄想用手机频繁下单当冲
因此当时常会发现许多不合理的单子与踪迹
同时
也如我之前的推想
股票进入主笔撮合时代后
比起集合竞价的时期
因为股票交易节奏与跳动模式变得与期货
海期选择权相同
更符合我的个性与手法
所以出乎意料的是
彻底进军主笔撮合的现货股票市场后
我几乎没什么转换期
月交易量一路从10亿
20亿
接下来30亿
40亿
80亿
100亿
200亿
一直到一个月850亿
正巧在2020年出现了史实级别的大波动行情
2020年3月份的波动幅度
是美国股票历史上最大的一个月份
平均每日震荡幅度接近6
比1990年网络科技泡沫
2008年金融海啸时都还要更大
幸运的是
在这个阶段
我对各种策略
各种商品
交易手法都算是相对成熟了
于是我同时做股票当冲
海外指数期货
海外商品期货
海外选择权
台指期
台指选择权
可转换公司债CB等
疯狂的交易人生就此彻底成型
热血的交易魂完全爆发
资产也开始大幅度增加
使我的资产与缴交的税收
都改用意来计算
2020年疫情爆发
新冠肺炎猖狂流窜
重击股市
3月美国股市暴涨暴跌
熔断边岸
只当股市价格波动达到限定幅度时
暂停交易一段时间的机制数次
甚至一天内就熔断四次
连股神巴菲特都感叹
活了89年
第一次经历到这种事
可怕程度超越2008年的金融海啸
走了十多年多头的美股带头狂泻
其他国家的股市也跟着跌
台股在两周内同步跌掉2000多点
各方专家纷纷出来试景
全球经济衰退要来了
小型金融危机风暴赶快卖股球线
波动式短线交易员的吃饭工具
尤其美国股市的波动
当时已经陷入完全的疯狂状态一下子是暴跌期市场启动熔断机制暂停交易15分钟一下子却又暴涨,一路涨到熔断这意味着趋势出来的时候走势会很强烈
也更意味着,在市场中不必硬要逆势跟市场对筑干
只要顺势交易,基本上趋势出去之后
什么时候进场都会赚钱
打进去,不对,停损
打进去,对了,爆
我的原则无他,就这两句话
这时候的我几乎是只凭损益来做交易了
再怎么厉害的分析在这种一下跌期
几分钟之后涨期
又过几分钟在跌5的短线波动行情前面
都是没意义的
对交易经验累积将近10年的我来说
我很笃定
只要跟注损益做就好
直到行情开始盘整为止
早上交易台指期
小日经
V50
下午交易
DUX
英国时报
蓝筹
再加上整天都有在交易的黄金
清原油
小纳
小道
小SP
因为每一种商品波动都那么大
也可以说几乎全部都用同一种策略来做交易
就是用损益
不过虽说短线走势分析没意义了
但当下我在交易时
还是会考虑到全球股市的相关性与联动性
最基本的就是
例如小SP在台股交易时间
跌到跌停
熔断
这种情况下
难道台股会自己往上冲到涨停吗
想当然而
这时候当然台股
台纸期的部分就可以跟住放空
在这种概念下交易
都会有不错的获利
当时局势
全球股市
各种商品都是如此剧烈的波动
而我只靠着掌握住这一套技巧
基本上有上工就有钱拿
而且各国股市都可以交易
都可以赚到钱
只是赚的多还少的问题而已
一整天下来
我连休息都觉得浪费
甚至觉得好像休息就会对不起自己
不断交易到无可自拔的地步
每天我早上七点多起床
就交易到下午一点半抬股收盘
接着小睡一下睡到两点半
又开始交易欧洲期货
一路交易到七点才休息一下
之后八点半又继续交易
直到凌晨四点多为止
这段期间
我吃喝都由太太帮忙拿到办公桌上
上厕所都要用跑的
两天才洗澡一次
可以说早中晚都在交易
这种日子一直持续到2020年5月中
波动渐渐变得不再那么疯狂
我也感到疲倦而结束
做出调整
往后海外市场的股
债
期
我只做较长周期的交易策略
而当冲就只做台湾了
回想起2020年那一波史诗级的恐慌行情
在我过去近十年的台指
海外期货
各股交易生涯中
我也已经看过无数次的市场恐慌局面
因此我能笃定地判断
当时市场的气氛绝对是很明确的恐慌
加上当时观察世界局势在疫情中的转变
我注意到南韩疫情自2月20日爆发后
一个月内就获得有效控制
韩国也顺势反弹
中国在封城解禁后
有上万人涌入安徽省黄山市
这些发展让我做出这样的解读
疫情总会过去
而且疫情过后不会是经济萧条
而是报复性消费
也就是说
人们会把过去这段时间
不能出门消费的欲望
一股做其释放出来
在这样的判断下
我也开始布局波段多单
主要是布局在台指期
台指选择权
权指股现货等区块
也因为历经恐慌的经验
我知道市场恐慌
是很难预料会到哪里的
但重点在于
除了资金控管以外
千万不要想买在最低点
要买在相对低点
就会只是赚多赚少的问题
许多投资者
尤其是那些专家或大师
总是自以为可以买在最低点
卖在最高点
总是相信自己可以精准判断各种行情
还可以留住现金避开空头
稳稳地近代市场打好底
最后再多头起涨前进场
并且一买进就获利
也难怪他们老是需要想些
有的没有的花招来为生
想一想
如果这些专家
大师真的会赚钱
那他们底下那几万人的社团粉丝
或者甚至可以说是信众
不就人人都赚钱
每个人都买在底部又卖在最高点
这样一来市场还有谁会赔钱
就像疫情时一样
人多的地方不要去
这种很多人看
很多人性的网络迷失和消息
也都不要去看
看了只是影响自己而已
其实在那段市场极度恐慌的时间内
不仅局势飘摇动荡
加上账面上的未实现损益
也可能出现大幅亏损
内心要说毫无动摇
是不可能的
但我坚持在那段时间内
不去关注所谓的专家说的话
凭记住过去的经验与自己推导出的策略
再三告诉自己
要相信自己
毕竟我可是靠交易为生的人
一定要有赚钱的霸气
避开赔钱的人一定不会大赚
且这种人就算看对赚钱
往往也只进场非常小的部位
等于抱不到真正的大行情
接着
行情如我所想的快速一转
但说实话
我当然也没预料到行情反弹后
还会直接力转过高点
后续行情也一路向上
我大约是在五到六月之间
看到报了一个多月的部位
在回到恐慌前的附近价位时
就把部位出清
这段行情会回到恐慌前的价位
是属于我事前已经预料到
其有把握的发展
我也靠着这一单
顺利多赚了几十桶金
再回来说当冲这部分
当时除了全世界股市震荡行情大以外
全世界的商品波段
行情变化也是非常剧烈
尤其是2020年4月20日结算的清原油商品
每天触发几次熔断机制都是很正常的事
清原油算是经过量化统计
趋势出来时行情最顺的交易商品
当然也变成海外部分当冲作手的主力商品
4月底那天是期货要转换到下一个月的最后交易日
边按只交割月份的最后一个交易日
在这一天期货的未平仓部位将进入交割流程
一早就明显感受到波动有异常
且因为是最后交易日
流动性也较差
这个因素也进一步导致波动速度与空间变大
那天
我一整天几乎都在关注并交易2020年5月份期货合约
而我注意到
随着结算时间接近
股价波动越来越大
从-10
-20
一直到9点跌到-40
12点变成-50
12点半又进一步变成-60
一点时滑到-70
接着是一点半的-80
两点的-99
没错
原油价格竟然跌至0元了
而我也从轻原油跌至10元的时候
开始一路往下做
一直交易到跌至0元
在0元的瞬间
我开始思考一个问题
既然是商品期货
不像指数或是股价
最低价格为0
会不会商品其实可以跌到负值
思及此
我立刻看了一下台湾各期货商下单价报价
发现其实是有道负值的
但无法下单
因此依照我平常的SOP
遇到这种问题
我马上打电话给期货商海外交易部门
得到的答案是
有可能会是负值
但他们也没看过
结算过负值的商品
且台湾还没期货商开放负值下单
边案
同年4月15日时
CME芝加哥期货交易所临时修改系统
可以处理负值的报价
但当时亚洲地区的期货商
仍无法用负值做交易
因为太多不确定性与不可掌控的风险
我当下做出决定
将所有空单部位
以及原本在林园附近
做的极短线部位全数出场
静观局面
最后的结论是
不仅全台湾
甚至是全世界
几乎都没料到
有这种价格降至零以下的可能性
以台湾期货商为例
没人可以下付值交易
所以清原油商品
最终到结算前约两点半的时间点
价格已经狂泄到-40元
也就是说
当天跌幅已经远远超过伏300
隔天的清源游6月合约
也延续了前一日的大波动
从20元一路狂跌70
这辈子可能也很难再有机会
遇到这种短短一天内
振幅就超过50的波动商品了
我有幸连续见证两天的历史奇观
也扎扎实实参与这两天的行情
从早打到晚
我第一天是从10元打到0元
直到券商系统限制问题
无法继续追击
零元之下的行情
才终于放弃
接下来第二天
又追着六月合约行情
从二十元打到十元
清元油真不愧是地表上
目前波动最大的商品
当时这只商品每天熔断数十次
光是两小时之内
就熔断了五次
可说是熔了又熔
熔了再熔
简直是价差交易者的天堂
这几天内屡屡出现一分钟
就爆出十的价差
或者两三分钟内
跑出20价差的情况
这种差异就相当于
台指期或一分钟内就涨跌1000点
或者两三分钟内涨跌2000点
而一整天的振幅可跑到50以上
类比到台指期
就相当于台指期一天出现5000点的振幅
事实上台指期从2020年1月崩盘开始
一路滑到当年度的最低点
都还没跌出5000点的跌幅
更不用说前一天
那个历史上最狂跌幅300了
这种数字几乎等于台值7,3万点的价差
在这样的大行情中
我集中精神在操作清云油期货
甚至连早上台股开盘期间都在打油
完全放掉台股市场的行情
所以我非常期待台湾有一天会进一步解放规定
开放无限制涨跌幅
到时当冲市场肯定会迎来一波新气象
想必会变得更好做且更加盛行
由于这波2020年的波动一直持续到年底
加上台股市场一些主流开始兴起
因此在年末将至时
我预期2021年绝对是大波动年
于是便将自己的交易额度提高
说到这边
有些人或许会觉得额度高是一件很恐怖的事
但其实真正恐怖的是
明明还无法提升绩效并稳定赚钱
却不想用小额度小资金练习
而是直接放大资金开始做
由于我是全职交易者
可以说是人生中只有交易这个工作
随着我在交易市场上稳定赚到钱
资产
也持续往上累积
这种放大额度的动作
对我来说是必然发生的
市场中常常听到许多亏损的经验谈
诸如我赔了一年的薪税
圆圈圆圈万
我年初才借出股票
就赔了圆圈圆圈万
但其实从生活中的例子
大概就可以看到
类似这些亏损经验谈的缩影事件
学生时期
朋友
亲戚聚在一起打牌
玩的钱大多不会太大
但当大家开始工作
有赚钱了
就会听到有些人开始鼓吹
大家都开始工作有赚钱了
我们赌那么小没感觉了
赌大一点了
反正你薪水赚那么多
然而这里说的有感觉
其实也展现出人性的难题
当你遇到自己没把握的赌局或游戏
你能做到好好把持住自己的贪欲吗
另一点就是关于省钱
回想一下
身边的亲朋好友中
是否也有这样的情况
明明已经每天都在喊没钱了
却还是继续上高档餐厅吃好料
旅游娱乐毫不手软
这是因为这些人在心态上就认为
反正省这些钱也不会比较有钱
对生活没帮助
而这也跟前面提到的感觉有关系
赚少少
省少少的钱
感觉不痛不痒
所以忽略这些小细节
转而去追求更有感的事物
想想我们从小到大的学习过程
都是先学会注音符号
才学会拼字
先学会加减法
才进阶到乘除
有一个循序渐进的过程
但对于股票交易这门学问大家却小看了学习过程的重要性不仅自动缩短了学习过程甚至有些人还觉得根本不用学也可以说大家没把这当成一门学问
只纯粹视为赌博游戏
有些人或许自认天赋异禀
不必花时间学
或者是以工作忙碌为由
懒得学习
关于心态面
再次暂且不表
我想说的是
在还无法稳定获利的阶段
为什么许多人会直接跳过
以最小单位或小资金
来练习做单的学习过程
一开始就大手笔买进许多股票
甚至动辄投入数十万
上百万的金额
不外乎就是上面提到的心态
这样才有感觉
对生活才有帮助
基于这样短时尽力的思考方式
违背从小到大的学习过程
急于求成
直接从高难度开始
贸然投入大笔金额
大肆豪赌
最后的结果当然是赔钱
有些人一赔钱就知难而退
离开股市
那种情况倒是还好
但当在股市中赔入的金额多到一个地步之后
这些人就再也回不了头
离不开股市
因为一想到自己已经在股市中投入过多
赔的钱可能是自己工作好几年才赚得到的金额
于是一种不甘心的心态油然而生
事前投入的沉默成本又使这些人进入赌徒模式
进入负向循环
他们会抱持一种侥幸心态
我把家里的钱都输光了
不赢回来对不起家人
如果能把这些钱都赚回来
我就不再这样赌了
这种状况恐怕都是会一路持续下去
直到输到真的没钱可输
借的钱也输光才会停止
这些人在惨痛的教训下
不仅发誓再也不碰股市
往后的余生还会摇身一变
成为宣传剧赌大使一工
当他们看到年轻人在碰股票
或是看到有人想学股票时
都会劝导他们好好去工作
不要玩股票不务正业
这些人凭着自己过去的金
燕就判定其他人进股市后
想必也会是不断赔钱
就像曾经的自己一样
但这时又可能出现另一种状况
当这些人看见股市的后进之辈
不但没有如自己预期般的赔钱
反而还在股市中一路顺遂
甚至赚到足以买车买房的钱
这种情况就会令他们心态崩溃
于是重入股市
又进入另一次赔钱的循环
如何才能结束这种负向循环呢
终究还是必须好好学习并做好停损
要不然就前脆认清自己不适合股市
把所有部位都除清
然后好好工作
股市绝不是像市面上某些不识广告那样
可以让你不用看盘轻松获利
甚至只要用手机点一点
就能无本获利的赚钱管道
第九章市场的顺势操作之道
随着我的每日成交量逐渐放大
当冲的手法与商品当然也逐渐改变
市场的为纳量
变成我做单时最主要的考量
而我在台股市场交易的商品
也渐渐地从什么标的都可以打
转变为只打全台湾成交量排行前30名
到最后演变为几乎只打前三名
像是2021年
航运股最热门的那段时期
我每天的买卖成交量合计
大概稳定维持在全台湾前三名
倒不是说小型标的不能缩小部位去打
而是对我来说
做小型标的
时间报酬比较差
加上打小型标的时
也会花费许多精神
最后我才决定
与其什么都做
还不如在没大型标的
可以打的时候休息
然后再聚精会神地
打大只的标的
我始终相信
交易是完全可以复制
训练的
若你练一个方法
练到熟练
也赚钱了
就会自然而然地放大
而当冲当然也是这样的状况
手法方面
人家都说说破不值钱
其实我的做法
就是跟大家一般认知的
当充技巧大同小异
只是量比较大一些而已
不过量大自然会有一些优势
例如当市场往上走时
我也经常多买一些
那么这个力道就会加成
加速市场往上的力道
所以说有时候大部位的优势就在这边
再者由于部位大小因素
渐渐的我执行顺势策略的比例
就慢慢提高
而逆势策略的交易则慢慢降低
在此
举例说明量大的优势
假设有一只持续长红的妖股
每天不断涨停板
经过判断
你相信市场已经过度乐观
再加上这只股票
今日终于没能锁住涨停板
研判买方能买的都买到了
表示下跌机会变大
这时候
当然可以尝试去做放空
如果是一般当充足
做出这个判断后
可能去空个一张
五张
这样的量对市场不会有任何的影响
但若是你资金量大,一口气空个一千张,五千张,这时市场其他参与者会因为感受到你的卖压,纷纷跟住抛售,而且原本做多的参与者也会因为发掘上方卖压沉重而缩手。
这样一来,市场的供给需求就会因为你的交易而受到影响,导致股价下跌机会反而增加了,这就是所谓量大的加成效果。
另外顺势做多当然也是一样的状况
假设目前大盘盘是很强
或者你看好一只股票
今天价格将要突破
涨势要发动了
也可能是你看好一只个股的基本面题材
这时候你买一张与买一万张比起来
买一万张的胜率反而会比较高
市场就因为你的买进
变成不容易下跌了
大家都在看的那些技术指标
也因为你的买进而翻多了
当然
没有交易是可以百分之百赚钱的
上面提的量大的加成
只是提高胜率
但所谓量大或是大部位
也不会是每一笔就直接499刷一排进去
边案
单笔交易超过500张即为巨额交易
需申报
因此主力大量买进时
往往都以单笔499张为单位买进
499变成为主力的代称
一般人当冲最怕看错方向
但我每天都会看错
所以要靠试单找方向
假如预设是百张的交易额度
就用十张去试单
部位越大
多空感受力道要越强
就要用更大的部位去试
像我可能会以一两百张去试单
有时在试单后几秒钟
就能迅速判断出方向错误
一旦赔钱且亏损部位扩大
当然我的部位就不会再开上去
但若是看对
我就会瞬间加满部位
让加成的效果显现出来
也因为时常看不准
相较每次交易胜率
我更在意的是赚赔比
而想要拉高赚赔比
就必须严格控制赔钱分母金额
扩大赚钱分子部位
赚或赔是市场说了算
所以只要控制好分母
也就是控制好赔钱
赚赔比就能拉开
我主要是做顺势操作
胜率不见得要高
但只要逮住一次行情
就会让赚钱部位尽量放大
尽量跑得更远
不过说到停损
小部位看错还可以轻松停损出场
大部位看错要出场就比较费神了
举例来说
如果你是做多后要停损
当你开始卖后
市场就可能被你的卖压吓到
更加引发一批卖压
恐慌情绪出炉
导致供给需求不对等
这种情况下
停损的幅度就会比较不可控
损失的金钱也比较疼
所以
如何在不影响市场太多价格的前提下停损
或者如何运用避险工具
就会是投资中最重要的考量
以2021年5月为例
有一次因为前一天航运股很强
我认为隔天因能延续多头涨势
于是一开盘就持续买进长荣
然而事与愿违
即使有我这样的大量买进
市场却没有因此看好
让需求大于恭敬
相反的却是卖压一直出笼
眼看部位越吃越多
我就立即判断该想办法退场了
当时长荣是大盘多空指标
我手上约有一万张的部位
要全数停损出场需要一段时间
过程中也会带动其他个股下跌
指数可能因此重挫
所以我的策略就是先放空避险
当下我赶紧进行避险
做空台指期
台积电
中红
同一时间也开始积极地停损长荣
果然符合预期
原本市场就已经是供给大于需求
当我的停损单一出来
不只是长融股价受到影响
全市场指标股
全值股等也同样遇到卖压出笼
股价下跌
后来
我在长融全数出拖的同时
进行避险单回补
多亏这样的停损策略
虽然当笔交易还是赔钱
却让我当天少赔了数百万元
这个例子能让我们清楚看见
为什么操作大部位时
必须比小部位更用心
更仔细地拟定进出场策略
尤其是还要思考到影响市场的层面
相对于小部位
大部位更需要事先规划好进退场动线
让大象转身时
不至于重心失控
被自己绊倒
但有时更吃得使临场反应
有时市场给你拟定这些策略的时间
可能只有数分钟到数秒钟
不过如果以成交量来作为经验值
相同的交易
我已经经历了数千
数万次
这样一来
我拟定策略的时间就可以缩短
也能够更细心地处理到许多细节
举例来说
有一次我在前一晚做研究时发现
上海出口集装箱运价指数
ASKFI因中国11长假
提早一天公布
且是那一年来第一次下跌
市场多数人不会每天做研究
大部分都是看到股价下跌
才去找原因
但是我前一晚就先拟定计划
大量做空航运股
只要隔天股价开盘没有开太低
就代表市场还未反映此消息
是做空的机会
隔日开盘
一确认到市场尚未反映
我就赶紧抓各种部位
因为像这种消息
当市场发现运价下跌时
股价一定会反应
比起价位好坏
我更注重看对可以吃多少部位
于是我就不计代价地开始放空
当然
在我开始大量放空之后
市场也惊觉到今日卖压沉重
纷纷去找原因
新闻也追着这个状况
开始大肆报道航运股重挫的原因
接着便是投资人争相抛售手中套牢部位
最后股价果然顺利跌停了
这几年来
交易损益不断成长
但我觉得比起交易手法的成长
更大的是心态面上的进步与转换
在投机市场中
要稳定赚钱的难度
远大于偶尔赚到一大笔钱
而要稳定赚钱
重点并非每次都要预测得很准
当我还没办法能叫稳定获利时
也跟我身边一些朋友
或者在网络讨论区中
看到的一些网友一样
总是会把重心放在研究
如何预测走势上面
但直到后来
我把重心放在研究自己身上
才开始能渐渐稳定获利
再次与大家分享
对我而言非常受用
也对我的交易
影响非常深的几句话
天下唯一确定的事
就是不确定性
交易的本质
就是犯错
市场的诱惑
养成操作者的讲性心态
这几句看似简单的废话
却是使我损益产生
转变的最大起点
当初听其他市场前辈
谈论研究自己
或是谈论诸如孙子兵法等策略时
我也只觉得非常玄
感觉就像是在故弄玄虚
只能说是非经过不知难啊
快速结论
在交易中想要长久获利
正确的方式并非找到一个
绝对有效的交易必胜法则
而是首先需要多方学习
了解理论与规则
接着再审慎观察市场局势
思考策略后再演你对策
进场时
不能把重心放在预测的准确度
因为影响股价的因子实在太多
比起预测走势
交易者更应该注重的是研究自己